"That's recording on that camera, Tom."
Lovely! All right.
Hello, I'm Tom Scott, and I've got a story
for you.
It's set in a future. Not necessarily the
future, I'm not saying this is what will happen,
but I think there's a plausible path from
where we are now to where we will be.
And where we will be is April 2022. Ten years'
time.
First person we're going to meet there is
Jason Stewart.
He's the MP for Tooting and Streatham. He
is the Minister for Social Development.
Considered kind of a hotshot among his party
after winning his seat in the 2020 General
Election in a very hard-fought contest.
Also embroiled in a massive scandal, but we'll
get back to that in a minute.
This is the 2022 iPhone. Looks about the same,
the laws of physics dictate you still need
a battery brick,
but what has changed is the mobile network
speed.
5G now blankets the country in hundred-megabit
internet access,
and data caps are a thing of the past.
Which means that last year, Apple reused a
trademark and introduced iLife.
It's quite similar to Your History on Microsoft
Nokia phones,
or Droid Locker on Android. They're all descendents
of the accountability systems
that have been used for police officers and
care workers for years now.
With iLife, the phone is always recording
audio
and sending it and your location to a cloud
server.
The descendents of Siri then generate a transcript
of it.
If you're talking to someone else with iLife,
it'll give you a text chat log,
it's not perfect, but it's close enough.
And if you have the new Apple headset, it's
got a couple of cameras embedded in it,
which are always recording video when they're
connected.
That's uploaded, analysed, and stabilised
by the same systems.
The cable, incidentally, still gets tangled
in knots every time you put it in your bag.
What this means is that you can say to people,
'this is what I'm looking at right now', or
'this is what I just looked at'.
It's all hooked up to social networks. This
is what people use it for.
Justin Bieber's comeback tour was livestreamed
round the clock, and never went below 50,000 viewers.
What's more important, though, is that iLife
gives you a lifelog.
A complete history of every person you've
talked to,
every friendly smile, every stranger you've
passed in the street.
Your own memory is now indexed, augmented,
searchable, and your first 50 gigs of storage are free.
And if you think that's farfetched, let's
remember Facebook is less than 10 years old.
Twitter is only six years old, and the iPhone
itself? Five years.
We've gone from T9 text entry to full voice
dictation in half the time we're talking about here.
Which brings us back to Jason Stewart. Jason
is a member of 'Cheshire Boys',
the site for old alumni of his public school.
It runs on Disco, a fairly popular community
framework,
that unfortunately has some fairly major security
flaws,
including one that allows mass stealing of
passwords.
Let's go to Russia. Natalia Orlowski is there.
She is 15, she lives in an ex-Soviet tower block
and she doesn't get out much.
She's running a bot that pulls in as many
of those passwords as possible.
Not for anything particularly evil, she saw
what happened to the group
that charged porn to Putin's credit card last
year,
but because she can, she takes all these passwords,
she bundles them together,
and she puts them out on a Pastebin site.
Because she can.
It's just another big leak, there've been
loads of them before,
and Facebook and all the networks will of
course lock everyone's account down
and require that they change their password
again.
But in the meantime, lots of people are looking
through this list and one person
is going to notice 'tootingjason@gmail.com'.
His password is 'stewart9',
that's the same password he uses everywhere,
and someone goes 'hey! Let's log into his
iCloud!'.
First thing they see is Apple's handy 'Is
This You?' feature.
Jason Stewart can be seen in a few frames
of this walkby in Shoreditch.
He wasn't recording, but his phone had his
location and facial recognition did the rest,
and it didn't take too much effort to find
out what he was doing there.
A few minutes later, this poison pen letter
arrives in
every single political editor and blogger's
inbox in the country.
The Sun eventually runs with it first, after
all the blogs have made it public knowledge.
And Jason Stewart's career is ruined.
Except it's not.
Because he's not committing a crime under
UK law.
He's divorced, so he wasn't even committing
adultery.
It's 2022. He decides he's going to go on
the offence.
He gets up in Parliament and says that
'our private lives should be private, and
we must investigate these hackers'.
And he convinces the Met to investigate, which
they do by
filing a request with Apple for any lifelogs
that mentioned Jason Stewart
in the hours and minutes before the leak.
And Apple agrees, because that argument got
settled years ago
after Blackpool.
So that's the way it works now. Someone's
arrested, sixteen years old, so they can't be named,
but we know they've been released on bail
on the grounds
that they not use the internet or a computer,
which means of course
that they can't do anything.
And that's the precedent set. If you're in
the same area as the victim of a crime,
or you say the same name as a victim of a
crime in the minutes or hours before,
your lifelog will get pulled and searched
through by the police.
And you can always close your account and
opt out, of course,
that option is right there, but it's so damned
useful.
And besides, all your friends use it.
And besides, lots of companies are requiring
that their employees use it
for liability purposes.
And besides all that, it's not like you've
got anything to hide, right?
I'm Tom Scott. Thank you very much.
(APPLAUSE)